when germany invaded poland in september
1939 britain and france having pledged
to defend it responded by declaring war
on germany
yet two weeks after german troops
crossed the border from the west
soviet troops invaded from the east and
as many of you will know
there wasn't a response but why why
didn't the allies declare war on the
ussr
so a bit of background throughout the
20s and 30s britain was particularly
concerned about polish
well existence and felt that it
guaranteeing polish independence
would be enough to deter foreign
aggression forever it was not
the british guarantee stated that it
would defend poland against an invasion
by a european power
the treaty did have a secret protocol
though that stated that european power
actually meant germany
and only germany in that in the event of
a soviet invasion britain and poland
would enter into discussions about
mutual assistance
france had also agreed to support poland
and much like britain only agreed to
defend it against german aggression
although france's agreement was much
more informal and was an arrangement
between the french and polish militaries
not their governments and so france
technically had no obligations to poland
whatsoever
a slight snag came when the ussr and
germany signed the molotov ribbon-trop
pact in which they agreed to supply each
other with much-needed materials and
expertise
the pact also secretly divided poland up
between them and also made clear to the
rest of the world that they were going
to economically support each other in
the coming years
so the reason that britain and france
didn't declare war on the ussr were
simple
they didn't have to although there is
some nuance to this
so after britain received word of the
soviet invasion from the east its
reaction was one of caution
the polish ambassador had approached the
british government and was like
maybe help to which britain said no now
this doesn't mean that britain was never
going to help it simply meant that the
uk was weighing its options and
prioritizing victory over germany above
all other things
including poland existing you see the
british government was aware that the
ussr and germany had spent the past half
decade denouncing each other
and now that poland had fallen there was
no buffer state between the two anymore
as such there was a strong belief that
britain and france need only hold out
until the two inevitably turn on each
other the french government held a
similar view but they also believed that
poland as of the soviet invasion no
longer existed
and that france declaring war on stalin
wouldn't do anything to help anyone
and to french strategists this was
actually a good thing since germany now
likely had to keep a large number of
troops on its eastern border meaning
that france would have a much easier job
in defeating germany just like in world
war one
and so when poland was conquered britain
pushed forward with the harshest
measures known
it wrote a strongly worded letter to the
ussr saying that the soviet invasion was
unjustified and frankly
not on in the end both the uk and france
opted to continue relations with the
ussr as if nothing had happened this was
done with the long view in mind
both felt that poland was entirely lost
in that defeating germany was now the
only goal
france stressed that soviet plans would
likely soon clash with german plans and
the two would soon be at each other's
throats for britain the policy was one
of caution and waiting to see what the
soviet
endgame was the soviet union was seen as
a potential future partner whose
industrial might and manpower would
greatly help in defeating germany
and if the cost of that help was east in
poland then france and britain were
happy to accept that
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patreon supporters
james bissonette john lucid danny
maloney a man of culture
marvin castell john bisquez mo rob
waterhouse
james castaneda aaron the white jordan
longley gustav swann
marcus azna rasheed ali fielder oink
oink
izzy spinning three plates david
silverman maggie paxkowski
spencer lightfoot winston k wood robert
wetzel anthony beckett lexi schwinn sky
chappelle and kelly moneymaker
also they'd have lost